vous pouvez filmer ici en grande partie d'
accord
celui-ci
oh
des plans grand angle en vous sentant proche de
la couleur mais voyez la distance et
voyez le glacier en arrière-plan voici
le même que nous avons vu hier
exactement exactement
euh
vous faites ce que vous voulez ce serait bien vous
continuez à jouer,
il y a environ 400 mètres
vers le glacier, il y a des
icebergs bleus à côté d'eux au milieu
si nous pouvions faire un cercle bas autour de
ceux d'environ 10 mètres
au-dessus du niveau de l'eau
ouais ça passe devant maintenant  mais d'accord
vraiment bas et bas autour d'eux mais environ
100 mètres de rayon autour d'eux d'
accord et vous pouvez le tourner de l'autre
côté ne vous tournez pas de mon côté car
vous êtes du même côté
vous pouvez
commencer par un cercle de gauche  ouais
un peu plus large, rapprochez-vous des
rochers à droite pour commencer avec
quelque chose comme ça ouais, puis tournez à
gauche de
l'autre côté du ouais
tout autour ouais
incroyable
un autre cercle complet et ensuite nous faisons un
ci de la main gauche  rcle autour d'eux
c'est plus bleu d'
accord pouvons-nous maintenant faire un cercle dans l'autre
sens
autour d'eux
ici d'
accord c'est bon pour moi merci peut-être que
nous allons
vers le bord du glacier la face
du glacier
derrière nous
a un peu de ciel bleu là-haut où est le
pale de rotor
un aigle à droite assis sur le
ouais
faire le tour et prendre une photo de ça ouais
ouais il est toujours là
menant ses ongles
oh il mange quelque chose je suppose
ralentis autant que tu peux
avoir un poisson je pense que quelque chose se tient
dessus  quelque chose ici
essaye de t'approcher un peu arrêtons d'
abord d'accord
il a le pied sur un rocher il essaie
de manger un caillou
c'est de la nourriture
je pense que ça va atterrir là-haut
plus loin
ouais il est parti ouais ouais s'est énervé
oh mon dieu  il est monté sur
quoi faire que voulez-vous faire d'
accord directement sur la face du glacier
peut-être aller directement dans le
coin droit de euh et le long du bord
encore comme nous l'avons fait hier
et je vais  regarder en arrière vers le le  pi
où il y a un peu de ciel bleu en
arrière-plan,
vous pouvez voir où le vent
tombe ici, puis c'est totalement calme une
minute
entre l'endroit où la glace et le rocher sortent
de la
ligne de jonction, puis tout droit vers le visage
alors montez ici  puis tournez à gauche
vous éteignez ça ouais vous tournez à gauche maintenant
ouais à partir de là d'
accord d'accord d'accord et quand nous arrivons,
continuez tout droit donc nous sommes
comme au-dessus du glacier plutôt
qu'au-dessus de l'eau d'
accord vous voulez suivre le glacier  ouais
tu suis la courbe autour mais je
veux être au dessus du glacier plutôt
que d'
accord d'accord
on va faire le code dans la même courbe
il y a un peu de glace bleue dans l'
air
11 heures
ont déjà des gros plans  de celui-ci hier donc
je ne pense pas que
nous ayons encore tourné celui-là hier celui-ci ouais
je ne pense pas qu'il était au même
endroit
car il est retourné ouais je
pense donc je suis presque sûr d'avoir l'
air plus spectaculaire que  hier est-
ce que ça va, je viendrai et obtiendrai un peu de
proximité  des e-ups alors d'
accord c'est assez du plan large
revenons nous rapprocher avec nous
votre
euh
une partie est propre une partie est sale dans
laquelle celle
-ci tombe non vous ne pouvez pas voir l'
eau bouger vous savez bouger
oh oui d'accord j'ai compris ça
juste avec la houle qui
souffle ouais
mon d'
accord qu'est-ce que tu veux faire euh
près du sommet de toute la glace qui
descend ici à basse altitude d'
accord rouler dessus il
y a une petite flaque d'eau de l'eau bleue
qui monte
à notre  euh oh
alors
oh
désolé de
voler un peu vite pour la vidéo
six
fois un peu
je veux descendre d'ici
ouais oscar or kilo 5526
position
b
oh ouais d'
accord euh d'accord fini pour ta pizza ouais
je veux revenir à la fin de  d'accord
avez-vous fait cela
je veux dire
hé
est-ce que la caméra tourne maintenant ouais d'accord nous
devons parler plus tard
un verre
ici à la fin ok en
tournant lentement vers la gauche
pas trop près  se
mais vous pouvez très bien comprendre comment ça
marche
bien d'
accord
nous devons changer la bande dans euh
peut-être une minute
laissez ça tourner pendant une minute puis
pas bleu comme hier pas d'
accord arrêter l'enregistrement